yo man um it's good to see you though
bro
uh i think last time we saw each other
was like right before [ __ ] got hectic
right before the whole world shut down
march yeah it was like march it was it
was about six seven months ago so like
things have definitely changed um
how have you been adjusting to just the
way the world is now
because i know usually you'd be on the
road right now yeah
grabbing all kinds of brown paper bags
like what's what's been the
the adjustment for you oh i've been
playing the game like video games
yeah i feel you like me too i don't know
like
i i got an addiction to war zone yo
warzone is um
addictive to say like it's like you
being a whole nother world i don't care
about my phone
i don't want to talk to nobody it's just
different
yeah that and then i just got the new
tony hawk well not the
the old tony hawk when i was a kid just
to heaven when i was little
yeah so when i was little i had it and
then they just put out the remastered
version so
i've been just just diving in man head
first that war zone
still uh i hope so yeah tony hawk's
still alive
that would be i feel like i would know
if tony hawk was dead
he was just on joe rogan like last year
i hope he's still alive shout out to
tony hawk
um so you've been playing a lot of video
games obviously you've been working joe
just wasn't
just war zone just sticking on war zone
uh how are you nice on war zone no
i'm not because i feel like i started
playing it too late
i did but because you know when you play
it too late then you get on it and
everyone's so good
playing so i don't got it until so yeah
i feel like i caught the wave a little
late because now like
i hop on and it's all these everyone's
so [ __ ] fine-tuned and good and i'm
just like i'm
getting smoked on there bro was you
playing our playstation
yeah ps4 what's up i'm about a pc and
everything that's how in tune i got into
it
i bought a pc you bought a a pc bro yeah
yo that's next level gaming that's like
siri when you find someone who's a
gaming pc you're like oh yeah you're a
real [ __ ] nerd for sure
you got the graphics card and the
[ __ ] chair and
yeah i bought me a chip bought a massage
super ill chair you probably got a
[ __ ] colorful ass keep like cut key
lighted keyboard you light up
i bet you do how much should you spend
on your gaming
pc uh 15 on it oh yeah that's that's
gonna
that's gonna fly big monitor oh i'm on
the tv oh yeah of course
okay i can't reach it's it's
cross-platform right like you'll be
smoking people who are playing on other
yeah that's just the thing is when
you're on um
when you're on like playstation stuff
like your timing like a half a second
late so if you're on the pc you got a
half a second advantage
yeah you're like you faster
that's hey that makes sense shout out to
everybody out there playing at uh
warzone